to this day has been the scariest thing
I've ever done in my life was quitting
my job it wasn't just quitting my job it
was what quitting my job signified about
everything else it meant that everything
that I had done at that point I had been
building this life that I didn't want to
live I was building a life that my dad
wanted me to live to get his approval
and the thing is when my approval rating
for my father was at its absolute
highest is when I was my absolute
saddest as a human being when I left
that job I basically started from
scratch and was like what do I want to
do once I was able to not care about his
opinion no one else's opinion really
came even close whoever that person is
you care the most about their approval
is I think the person that you need to
be willing to get disapproval from to do
what you want to do